Predicting how the Netherlands will line up at the euros in 60 seconds.
It's crazy to say with the young starting in midfield,
but the most crucial part to this team has to be Javi Simmons.
Brooklyn will start in goal
and although Daily Blend always seems to get on the team sheet,
I expect Hartman, Nathan AKK,
Van Dyke and Grtorida to make up 4 out of the 5 defensive positions.
The right wing back is gonna be the hardest prediction on this team,
but the left winger isn't so easy either.
Now there are plenty of options to place alongside Frankie De Young,
but the two that will really challenge are rinders and Weaver.
While rinders is a more attacking player,
Matt's Weaver will offer a more balanced option
and he'll bring a defensive reliability that Cohen should favor.
This could be a massive tournament for him.
My girls will get minutes.
But given his form this season,
Brian Brobby is the best option at the nine
and he'll likely start if he's fit.
Now there's quite a few options on the left side of attack,
but given his resurgence this season,
I wouldn't be surprised if Daniel Malin gets the nod.
That would mean players like Cody Gakpo,
Memphis Dupuy and Noah Long would all come off the bench.
As for the debate at right wing back,
almost everyone will argue for Jeremy Frampongen.
For good reason with what he's doing this season.
But I just expect Coleman to stick with Dumfries